okay we do have a voicemail number that
number is a two one nine two david p two
one nine two david p here's an
interesting and completely sincere
question from a viewer take a listen to
this any day but i'm wondering um when
is the first time you really question my
sexuality and how did that come out you
know to to I guess that I mean will be
the first option how did he take that
and was he responsible or was he sort of
immature Thanks yeah so good completely
sincere question it's funny by the way
obviously what they're saying is when
did I start to question my sexual
orientation the answer being never when
I was like five I knew I liked girls but
a lot of people say sexuality which is
not sexual orientation second if you
actually look at the definition of
sexuality it's something else and it's
almost like a Freudian slip in a sense
or it's like you're not even really
asking me about what you think you're
asking me about but in any case Pat took
it all very professionally I disclosed
to Pat during the hiring process that I
am exclusively dating women and Pat said
that that was completely fine and he was
completely responsible and professional
in every way and we've had no problems
whatsoever thank you so much
shockingly now this is I hesitate to
even say this because I don't want to
offend people we we got back from
vacation and I had several hundred
voicemails to go through to see what
could I use on today's show that was the
best thing in terms of you know when I
listen to the voicemails I'm listening
to is there a funnier interesting point
what's the caller's connection like how
long is the voicemail some people leave
a three-minute voicemail and then it
maxes out that's the max and then they
call back and say they need to add on to
it like have we ever played a
five-minute voicemail on the show no
once I eliminated bad audio people that
are droning on and on and on things that
just aren't interesting unfortunate
some people who seem to maybe not be
totally well who callin regularly I
actually didn't have that many short
pithy interesting ones so you know that
that's what we ended up with it's
disappointing but alas such is life and
that's so we're working with what we've
got that's all I can really do and yes I
know Eggman you sent a couple your audio
was disastrous during them and it was
completely unusable in every way on
today's bonus show we will be talking
about my vacation to Aruba I will talk
about the culture I will talk about the
cuisine I will talk about the geography
I will talk about all sorts of other
things from my trip on today's bonus
show we will also hear from producer Pat
who went on I've deliberately not asked
him anything about it yet Pat was on
another one of these Road Trip
extravaganzas this one ideally
short-circuiting the car trouble thing
because instead of doing the entire trip
in a partially already broken-down van
he flew out and rented a car for the
beginning of the entire thing
national parks Vegas all sorts of other
stuff so I've heard nothing about it and
we're gonna hear about it on the bonus
show so if you don't have access to the
bonus show become a member at WWE at
medCom
or become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show both will give you
instant access to the bonus show if
you're not going to see any of that
stuff because you're not a member or a
patron you can see some of my vacation
pictures and videos on my Instagram page
at david dot Pakman on instagram but
listen you're really not going to get
the full scope of it from three pictures
and one video become a member if not for
anything other than hearing my vacation
stories which are substantive to say the
least I'll speak to you then